[موسيقى]
طبتم وطابت اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى بانوراما
وهذه عناوينها
التقرب السعودي ماذا يعني وهل اختلف
المشهد في المنطقه وهل يراهن الاسد على
السعوديه والخليج بدلا عن مصالحه اردوغان
ضربات امريكيه على مواقع ميليشيات مواليه
لايران في سوريا ردا على هجمات مماثله هل
هي تحذير فقط ام نهج جديد في التعامل مع
طهران
رجيم
في اول ظهور جماهيري له بعد ازمه اتهام
المدعي منهات ترامب يتهم بايدن باستغلال
سلطاته لاقصائه عن الانتخابات من الجاني
ومن الضحيه
اهلا بكم بعد الاتفاق السعوديه الايرانيه
على اعاده العلاقات خطوات ايجابيه تشهدها
المنطقه مع قرب استئناف الخدمات القنصليه
بين المملكه السعوديه وبين سوريا بعد قطع
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه قبل اكثر من عقد
قناه الاخباريه الحكوميه نقلت عن مسؤول
بوزاره الخارجيه السعوديه قوله انه في
اطار حرص المملكه على تسهيل تقديم الخدمات
القنصليه الضروريه للشعبين فان البحث جاري
بين المسؤولين في المملكه
ونظرائهم في سوريا حول استئناف تقديم
الخدمات القنصليه الحديث عن التقارب تبعته
وسائل الاعلام ووكالات الانباء العالميه
التي قالت ان سوريا والسعوديه اتفقت على
معاوده فتح سفارتيهما في خطوه اعتبرتها
تمثل دفعه كبيره لعوده دمشق الى الصف
العربي وكان وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير
فيصل بن فرحان قد اشار خلال للامن في
فبراير الماضي الى ان اجماعا بدا يتشكل في
العالم العربي على انه لا جدوى من عزل
سوريا
مضيفا ان الحوار مع دمشق مطلوب في وقت ما
حتى تتسنى على الاقل لمعالجه المسائل
الانسانيه بما في ذلك عوده اللاجئين
ينضم الينا من الرياض جاسر الجاسر الكاتب
الصحفي ومن دمشق عبر سكايب عبد الحميد
توفيق الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا بكما
بدايه يعني لابدا اولا من الرياض ومعي من
هناك جاسر الجاسر الكاتب الصحفي هذا
التقارب السعوديه السوري هل هو تقارب ام
تغير في معطيات المشهد ككل
نقول انه هو تقارب قائم على تغير في
معطيات المشهد هو نتيجه لهذه التغير اصبح
هذا التقارب قائم هي المساله المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لديها نقاط محدده وواضحه
في طريقه التعامل مع الملف السوري وهذه
مساله حيويه سبق انطرحها الامير فيصل
فرحان وطرحت اكثر من مره في اكثر مناسبه
وبعضها يعود الى سنتين او ثلاث سنوات هي
نفس الافكار اذا نحن نتكلم اليوم على
مرحله مهمه اولا لنقل المملكه حريصه على
تحقيق الاستقرار في المنطقه
بشكل عام بعيدا عن الاشكال سوريا ايضا
دوله تعاني من تمزقون يعني العالم
والمملكه اذا اكتشفت خلال كارثه الزلزال
مدى المعاناه في ايصال المعاناه المساعدات
الى السوريين متى التمسك نحن نتحدث على
فصائل متعدده كل منها تسيطر على جهه معينه
وتديرها اذا المساله هل نحن نعم بحاجه الى
اعاده الملف لماذا الان انا اعتقد انه
دمشق قدمت بما يشبه بدايه على الاقل
ضمانات وتعهدات بانها ستقوم بالخطوات
المطلوبه لتكون ولذلك انا ارى انه مساله
الخدمات القنصليه مثلا انسانيه ملحنه
نتيجه لكثره يعني انهم مليون سوري في
السعوديه الان وهذا متضررين هذا جانب
انساني ايصال المعاناه المساعدات يعني
السوريين في مناطق مختلفه من سوريا هذا
جانب انساني يقوم به مركز الملك سلمان
الاغاثه النقطه الاخرى هذه نعتقد هي تشابه
الى حد ما
الى الاتفاق السعودي الايراني شهران
للقيام بخطوات معينه فتح خدمات قنصليه
لابداع مؤشرات ايجابيه في تحقيق تقدم افضل
في المسار والوصول بالتالي استيعاب وادراك
مدى الجديه والرهان عليها وبالتالي الوصول
الى مرحله متقدمه في هذا الملف طيب الى
دمشق ومعي من هناك الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
عبد الحميد توفيق سيد عبد الحميد يعني
تقارب ثنائي بين الرياض ودمشق ام انعكاس
للمشهد على هذا الملف
مساء الخير لحضرتك الكريم والاستاذه
المشاهدين اعتقد بان انه تحصيل حاصل
لمجريات التحركات والتحولات التي حدثت في
المنطقه في الاونه الاخيره وتحديدا منذ ان
طرق التركيه الباب باتجاه سوريا لاحداث
حاله من التقارب وطي صفحه الماضي هذا
الخطوه التركيه كانت قد سبقت بخطوات عربيه
على راسها الامارات العربيه المتحده منذ
عام 2018
باعاده افتتاح السفاره ثم تطورت العلاقه
وكذلك كان هناك بعض الزيارات من قبل وزير
الخارجيه الاماراتي الى دمشق وكان الرئيس
السوري قبل سنه من هذه
قام بزياره اذا الى ابوظبي
في كل هذا المشهد اعتقد بان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لم تكن غائبه عن هذا
الموضوع ولم تكن بعيده عن كل هذه الحركات
التي تحدث على المستويين العربي السوري
وعلى مستوى حتى السوري في الاقليم مجمل
التحولات التي حدثت في هذه المنطقه في تلك
في تلك الفتره ادت الى ان تبدا هذه
العمليه بالنضج اكثر فاكثر وكان هناك
المواقف السعوديه المتواتره وكما ذكر ضيفك
الكريم من قبل وزير الخارجيه السعودي في
اكثر من محفل في ميونخ ومؤتمر ميونخ وكذلك
كان في دافوس يتحدث عن انه لا بد من انهاء
هذه العزله يجب ان يكون هناك حديث مع
الجانب السوري الواضح بان الجانب السوري
ايضا التقط هذه المواقف العربيه وبدا يبني
عليها كثيرا وكذلك التقط الموقف السعودي
واتحدث بايجابيه الرئيس السوري في
الامارات منذ حواليه عشره ايام بان الموقف
السعودي لم يكن كما كان غيره من الدول
التي وقفت ضد الدوله السوريه هذا هذا هو
السؤال لماذا الولوج الى الحضن العربي كما
يقال لدمشق عبر الباب السعودي وليس عبر
الباب التركي كما كان له ان يراد لماذا
وضع الرئيس السوري اشتراطات للتقارب مع
انقره
طبعا المساله هي اولويات ولكن هناك فرق
كبير بين التعاطي السوري مع السعوديه كبلد
عربي شقيق له وزنه وفي المنطقه وله وزنه
الاقليمي وله وزنه على كل الصعد السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والسعوديه لا تعادي دمشق ولا
تعادي سوريا ولا تعادي النظام لكن على
الجانب الاخر على الجانب التركي سوريا
تسيطر على اراضي عفوا تركيا تسيطر على
اراضي سوريه في الشمال سوريا تدير وترعى
وتدعم فصائل مسلحه معارضه للدوله السوريه
والنظام السوري تركيا ايضا تدير جبهه
النصره الموصوفه ارهابيا حتى في تركيا وهي
تسيطر على جزء كبير من ادلب لذلك هنا
الموقف مغاير تماما والمقاربات غير وارده
في هذا الاتجاه هنا دوله عربيه شقيقه يمكن
ان تبني مع سوريا وسوريا تبني معها علاقات
على اسس واضحه وسليمه من تاريخ من مستقبل
والواقع حاضري بينما هناك دوله فيها كانت
على مدى 20 سنوات كانت تقف في الخندقه
المعادي للدوله السوريه والحكومه السوريه
طيب سيد جاسم الجاسر يعني اعود الى الى
ترتيب المشهد اليوم نتحدث عن مشهد ربما
تقود هذه المصالحه بين السعوديه وايران
الصين ايضا هناك توتر في المنطقه بين
الولايات المتحده وايران هناك معارضه
لعوده ايران الى الاتفاق النووي من قبل
اسرائيل وحتى تريد الضغط على الدول
الاوروبيه كل ذلك الترتيب للمشهد يدفعنا
الى التساؤل هذا التوقيت قبل القمه
العربيه
هذا التوقيت لترتيب الملفات والاولويات
الا يحتاج الى قياده عربيه واضحه لقياده
هذا الملف ملف ترتيب الاوراق العربي
وترتيب البيت العربي العربي
اعتقد ان القياده موجوده المملكه مع الدول
الشريكه وهي تعمل في هذا السياق لنتذكر
سابقا القمه السعوديه العربيه في العربيه
الامريكيه في الرياض والقمه الصينيه
العربيه في الرياض هذا جهد من العمل
المشترك يمكن تمتاز المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بين دوله لا يعني مثلا لو اخذنا
في الملف السوري لا علاقه لها فيما يحدث
في الملف السوري داخليا ليست منتميه لا
تدعم فواصل ولا تحرض احد على احد ولا وليس
لها حتى حدود مباشره من سوريا في الملف
الايراني ايضا حينما جاءت ايران ومده اليد
وحرصت وهي كانت تغرق في الرمال المتحركه
وقتها السعوديه متى تذهب سعادتها ووقعت
الاتفاق معها اذا هناك التوجه الى ان يكون
هناك عمل عربي المملكه تسعى اليوم فعلا
واضح وهذا خط اساسي في سلسله المملكه
لمعالجه لكنها ليست هدايا مجانيه لن نتفق
ان المساله نتطلب جهد نحن نقول نعم عوده
سوريا ضروريه لكن بماذا هل انه عفا الله
عما سلف ثم نبدا صفحه جديده كما نحتاج
الاستقرار لسوريا الاستقرار لا يمكن ان
يتم في الوضع الحالي بهذا الشكل لابد من
العمل المشترك على ابعاد الجماعات
الارهابيه لابد من ابعاد العذر على
الايرانيه ومن حزب الله والايرانيه مباشره
نحن نرى ما تعانيه سوريا من الضربات
الاسرائيليه بسبب هذا الايراني نحن نعاني
الشلل اللي تواجهوا التالي المملكه تدفع
نظام ونعتقد انه ما كانت الخطوات الا ان
هناك عدد التاكيد ان هناك رسائل سوريه
قويه جدا هذا التوقيت توقيت ترتيب الاوراق
سيد جاسر يعني ياتي حتى قبل انعقاد القمه
العربيه المرتقبه هل قد يعاد الكرسي الى
سوريا مره اخرى ويعاد التمثيل السوري
والله انا اعتقد اذا كان هناك تفاعل سريع
من من دمشق في هذا الجانب والقيام
والخطوات انا اعتقد انه ممكن يكون الاعلان
يعني هذه فرصه ذهبيه وفرصه ممتازه لان
التاخير سيؤدي في النهايه يمكن لا تجميد
المسائل الرساله وصلت الجهود بذلت اعطي
الفرص كل الامكانات هناك فقط خطوه يجب ان
تقوم بها دمشق لتحقيق هذه النقطه وهي
التزام الكامل بالتعهدات التي طرحت فيما
يخص تحقيق الاستقرار والعداله في سوريا
والنظام الشامل وحقوقهم الشعب السوري
وبالتالي اذا وصلنا النقطه نعم انه سيفتح
الباب كاملا الجميع حريص على سوريا هنا
الجانب السوري هو الذي يجب ان يكون
المبادره من لديه للقيام بالخطوه واضح
قابله والسريعه والعمليه لتحقيق ذلك السيد
عبد الحميد توفيق يعني ما قاله وزير
الخارجيه السعودي بدفعه كبيره لهذه
العلاقات بين البلدين ولكن ايضا قال انه
بحاجه الى حوار مع دمشق بحاجه الى ترتيب
الاوراق حتى عوده اللاجئين دمشق جاهزه
انا اعتقد بان سوريا اصبحت الان او تقدمت
خطوات واسعه في اتجاه التقاط الفرصه سادحه
من الجانب العربي عموما ومن الجانب
السعودي تحديدا بعد ان ترتبت كثير من
اوراقها مع بعض الدول العربيه ايضا
الوازنه والفاعله واعتقد انها تنظر الى
الجانب الى المبادره السعوديه او الى
التوجه السعودي اذا صح التعبير تنظري اليه
بكثير ايضا من الاهتمام واعتقد ان كثيرا
من الملفات التي تم طرحها بين الجانبين من
تحت الطاوله كما يقال ذلك قد توصلوا الى
قد وصلت بين الا الطرفين الى مراحل متقدمه
خصوصا ان المباحثات الامنيه بين الجانب
السوري والسعودي مضى عليها ما يقارب السته
اشهر كما نعلم ثم اضيف الى هنا ان هناك
حديثا عن وجود ايضا تواصل دبلوماسي بمستوى
اقل من
وزير خارجيه بين الجانبين
وهذا يعني ان الخطوات الاوليه التي كانت
قيد البحث قد تم تجاوزها او على الاقل وضع
عطر محدده للسير بهداها في خريطه طريق
واضحه الحديثه اليوم عن ان القنصليه
السعوديه تفتح قبل العيد او بعد العيد عيد
الفطر هذا نعم له جانب ثاني ولكن لا يمكن
ابعاد او انتزاع البعد السياسي في هذه
الخطوه وبالتالي اعتقد بان الجانب السعودي
قات لديه الكثير من القناعه بان دمشق
لديها الاستعداد لكي تقتل الخطوه المطلوبه
منها فيما يتعلق بالتفاعل مع هذه
المبادرات التي تطرح سواء من الجانب
العربي عموما او من الجانب السعودي بشكل
محدد واليوم المشهد يبدو انه ملائم
والتوقيت اعتقد انه مناسب في ظل العاملين
اساس او الاتفاق السعودي الايراني وكذلك
الرغبه التركيه في فتح صفحه جديده مع
المحيط العربي ومع سوريا تحديدا من دمشقى
عبر سكايب عبد الحميد توفيق الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك وكذلك من
الرياض جاسر الجاسر الكاتب الصحفي جزيل
الشكر لك
[موسيقى]